[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
house looks good actually they came I'm
pretty cool
how's your house looking mm-hmm
renovations it's not cheap that's all I
know it's not cheap I spent good about
money here
it's weird they're kind of similar
they're both kinda like modern farmhouse
hey did you say that tuitions due for
their school right mm-hmm both their
schools okay so we have the school
tuition we got we got to take your
clothes shopping that's what we're gonna
do that she grows like every freaking
day and every time we go shopping Ryder
was so fast I wanted to talk to you
about it come across this deal is
enrolling height margin very small all
right so we've been flipping houses for
a very long time and obviously things
have changed the markets different and
we're not making a hundred grand a flip
anymore and that's reality alive
expenses have gone up obviously we have
two households now and if we're gonna
make the same amount of money we have to
flip twice as many houses so that's
twice the amount of work and because of
that we have to take some risks
start flipping houses going for lower
margins still breathe they make me go in
that and they crawl on me yeah no I
don't but they meet me
can you go tomorrow morning after I drop
off that's cool yeah I saw
[Music]
[Applause]